make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
this is it ladies and gentlemen ladies
and gentlemen of the rob core this is it
we are done now after after weeks and
what's probably actually been a couple
years in reality after
you know postponements and delays and so
on and so forth we are now
finished remastering our run of
hickman's avengers and new adventures
and this is probably one of the best
endings
to a comic book run ever so we initially
pick up here
in the remains of a alternate reality
right this is designated
earth one one two zero zero zero six
right just arbitrary numerical
designation and this is basically the
ruins of a of a shattered map maker
world right this is a universe where you
used to have map makers here the world
for the most part been totally destroyed
and it looks like it was destroyed by
the combined forces of
hyperion thor the ex-nihili abyss star
brand
and night mask but regardless of the
situation they're basically nearing the
death of this universe right the stars
are blinking out the whole nine yards
this whole universe is coming to an end
and they basically found another map
maker but the issue is they're trying to
figure out where exactly they need to go
to locate the ivory kings the beyonders
right now
this does take place before the whole
scenario with like doctor doom versus
the beyonders in the previous video that
we did
and so i guess we can kind of throw this
in there but nonetheless it's it's cool
it's amazing right just bear with me
here and so what they're trying to
basically figure out is
where exactly they have to go right now
they can still essentially crack
the uh the the maps basically of the map
makers right crack their kind of
frequency
and locate where they have to get to and
night mask is basically the one that
says that like we can get there right
like i can get us there the downside to
this
is that once he finally figures out
where they have to go and he basically
teleports them to a new reality
is that with the nature of night mask
the the problem that he has is that he
can teleport them to anywhere they need
to go but as he does this he basically
ends up experiencing
temporal regression meaning the further
he jumps the more power he uses
the younger he gets and this is just
kind of a way for hickman to kind of
write his character out because with
them basically teleporting with him
teleporting them to the location they
need to go to
what it does is it reverts him all the
way back to a point where he's literally
just cells right so he essentially
ceases to exist he just ages down to
effective nothingness
and that gets rid of night mask right
but what it does is it leaves them in
what looks like this massive empty void
right on this chunk of rock from this
alternate reality they teleport to this
this giant empty void but they see
a sliver of light and they're met by the
beyonders right they literally say we
are beyond dreamers destroyers all of
reality our whim who dares stand before
us and unlike the response of doctor
doom the response of thor
is one of a warrior right he says gods
legends the very best of heroes you face
avengers this day
who dares stand before us and the
beyonders respond two will stand
and when these beyonders show up they
see them as interlopers right they're
like you're you don't belong here right
this
experiment that we're doing this work
that we have the power we possess
what we are is way beyond you like go
back home
enjoy what little happiness you have
left in your existence because soon
everything you know will come to an end
right everything you know will be
destroyed here and the response of thor
is not a chance right i don't run but
even if i did there's no safe place for
us to run to but this experiment
needs to end right has had unforeseen
and terrible consequences and they're
like it's not consequences
we intended this we intended it to be
this way and then in turn like when thor
tells them to stop they say no
thor launches his attack he throws his
hammer right it does nothing to these
guys i mean these are beyonders right it
does
nothing to these guys and they in turn
literally split the rock that they're on
where they they fire a thorst and them
crashing back down you know and
basically says like the the
like just let this happen right the
sooner you walk away from this the
sooner this experiment ends the sooner
it'll all be over
everything will be easier right hyperion
goes into the attack hyperion doesn't do
anything against them either right
that's when
abyss starts to realize the nature of
these beyonders right she says like
these
form that you see this structure that
you see is like an outward shell right
it harnesses it contains the energy that
they have
but if you can break past it you can
access their true forms we're
x in the healing we modify life if we
can access their actual forms we can re
we can
basically like modify them we can
re-materialize the very essence of what
they are
and turn them into something else and
that's exactly what happens these all
these ex nihili with the exception of x
mihilo himself and abyss all the other
ex nahili
literally just kind of surround this
this uh beyond her and then in turn
starts to like
to access its core energy and when they
do that they start to restructure him
alongside abyss and alongside ex nihilo
they start to restructure and reform the
very nature of this guy and literally
just turn him into a giant tree
but what it basically does is it
essentially neutralizes this beyond it
right it's kind of death in the
traditional sense instead of like
killing it they kind of move it to a
different state of existence but it's
basically just kind of in a null state
now it can't go back and restructure
itself it's been completely and totally
modified and reconfigured right and so
that just leaves one beyonder there
thor in turn goes on his attack and then
literally has his has his arm ripped off
right so like thor is basically
neutralized and then where star brand is
still there remember starbrand has
a huge amount of power he's got enough
power to wipe out an entire world if he
needs to he's got enough power to face
off against whatever threat he's facing
off against right to like defeat that
threat
and so ultimately he ends up getting
impaled by this beyonder and what it
does is it kind of creates this fracture
within himself right he has all this
star brain energy that he can't quite
contain
at that point hyperion jumps in and
hyperion literally tells this guy
like you know like yes they can move
fast but fast is light not a chance like
i'm the sun right and just like fires
all of his all of his energy you know
from his eyes directly at this beyond
the beyond grabs him and says foolish
creature i create stars i destroy them
what makes you any different and gouges
out the eyes of hyperion but then you
suddenly have star bran who comes in
when this bianna goes into the final
attack to kill thor
you have star brand who comes in and
star brand's like i didn't want any of
this
right like like here i am universes away
from the place that i call home i should
be back with the people that i know
holding on to them in these final days
instead
i'm stuck universes away fighting off
against you i never wanted to be here i
never wanted this life
this sucks right and like all this
energy lets loose and then he basically
just annihilates to be on it right he
totally destroys him and this is when
you get to the single
best part of this comic right you have
thor and you have hyperion they're the
only ones left right all the x and the
helia are gone x nihilo abyss star brand
night mask they're all gone these are
the only two
left and hyperion's initial response was
like star brand did it he destroyed that
beyonder we won right like like we
basically want
you know and thor's kind of like i mean
our business isn't finished here yet
like we still have this rift we have to
kind of find a way to close it my
periods like dude that's the least of
our concerns man like
like we close this thing we can go home
and it'll all be done and
they're kind of celebrating for a minute
right they're like man like we finally
came out on top of this and then and
then hyperion looks off in the distance
and says thor
we've got a problem and that and looking
back at that rift that's when they
suddenly see
more beyonders coming there's even like
there's there's hundreds of beyonders
pouring out of this thing
and looking at the fate that befalls
them the response of hyperion is
we're gonna die here today and the
response of thor is yes
but if we do let it be on our terms
right one more time
and then he goes to try to pick up his
hammer and he can't lift it right now
remember
this is the hammer of a thor who's
unworthy what this means is that odin's
son
has regained his worthiness right he's
regained his worthiness to wield his own
hammer but his hammer is not here and he
finds it hilarious it's only in the face
of his impending death does he does he
become worthy again and he says the hell
with it right like i don't need that
hammer like all i need
is this battle axe i need yarn board
that's it if i'm gonna meet this threat
then let me meet it as my father's son
right i don't want to meet it as some
unworthy thor able to wield a hammer
that doesn't really belong to me that's
fine like let me meet it as a warrior
let me meet it as the son of odin right
the king of asgard
and so he tells hyperion like you know
this occasion demands that i offer you a
drink but we don't really have any and
hyperion's like yeah man that's because
we drank it all
and thor's like yeah man we did there's
nothing left now but the other thing and
hyperion's like you know for some time
when i survived the the destruction of
my world i fell into a dark place but i
fell into a place where i didn't know
who i was
i didn't know where i was going i didn't
know what the value or the meaning of my
life was but you thor have shown me the
warrior's way
you show me what it meant to be a great
warrior a great man to be a great king
to be a great leader
you show me what it truly means to be a
hero and so i
ask when we die will you wait for me and
valhalla and thor says brother
this day i will race you there right
these beyonders come pouring out of this
portal right thor and hyperion
race into that they're just like dude
okay you know if we're gonna die we're
gonna die
in like the great dude these guys go out
like heroes man
hickman has like the best best
description ever he says against the
bleak nothing of dead space
two gods fell against many the sun shone
one last time there was lightning
and thunder and then silence so false
thor and hyperion probably the best
ending to like two heroes ever it's like
the most warrior ending
ever right they're like like we're
hopelessly outmatched there's no
possible way that we can win
who cares man if we're gonna die we're
gonna die in the most
warrior way ever right it's absolutely
amazing
so at this point we jump into the
conclusion of all of this right the
ending of the whole thing right the
whole whole thing like the stephen king
story and into the whole damn thing like
that's that's what this is
and so what we end up doing here is we
basically pick up with captain america
and iron man now i think initially i'd
skipped over this when we first covered
when we did our original run uh
hickman's avengers new avengers but in
hindsight it's extremely important
right because in in some of the previous
videos that we did we mentioned that
there was some point along the line
when captain america and tony stark met
and and it was it was kind of you know
after the events of of like superior
iron man and so on but whatever it was
that happened in this meeting transpired
in such a way to where captain america
totally lost faith in tony stark right
he saw him as public enemy number one
and this is really kind of you know
following the revelation of like the
incursions and all that kind of stuff
right so
this was this this right here kind of
reveals to us the worst thing that tony
stark did
right because what you have here is you
have the two of them meeting in a
restaurant now they're also met by
tamara who's there as a waitress now a
lot of you guys probably know
her as captain universe and you're
probably kind of asking yourself in the
early videos
what happened to captain universe right
like where did her character go
this is where she went to right that
ultimately tony stark ended up finding
the daughter of tamara and then
basically bringing her daughter to her
which is kind of one of these these
things that originally captain america
found admirable about tony stark right
he's a billionaire
like he can have the party life and all
that kind of stuff but instead he still
finds time to worry about the small guys
and it's one of these things where you
know with everything that's happened
name with a submariner joining the cabal
the fact that like the the world's
governments had turned wakanda
over to the cabal so that the cabal
could have a base of operations it's
what the cabal demanded right like we'll
do what we can to save your universe but
give us wakanda in turn basically the
world's nations turn their back on
on black panther's uh kingdom right like
a place that they should have kept
protected uh and and ultimately because
of the good that like black panther had
done for the world right like vibranium
and all that kind of stuff they turned
their back on him and betrayed him right
like despite everything that's happened
that at the end of the day
captain america kind of asked the
question like you plan for everything
like have you planned for what happens
if you fail and the response of iron man
is i mean if we fail then like
everything dies
how can you not understand that that's
why we can't fail that's why we have to
keep on fighting the good fight that
kind of a thing and
it's kind of nuts because he makes a
comment about neymar joining the cabal
and the response of captain america is
like you know you guys were off doing
the same thing when you were part of the
illuminati what's happened to you and
that's when tony stark picks up on where
captain america is coming from he's like
you really see me as
is like the bad guy like you don't see
who i really am like i'm the hero i'm
trying to do the good thing
i'm trying to keep the world protected
i'm doing what i always have been doing
that's why we have the avengers machine
and that's why we have all these things
going on
it's to be the hero to be the good guy
the guy who does good things and is tony
stark trying to convince captain america
that he's not a lost cause here and
that's when he asked the question like
do you recognize our waitress and that's
when captain america realizes that it's
tamara
and that's when he realizes that like
tony stark had gone and found the
daughter of tamara and brought the two
together and that's when he when he kind
of tells captain america like you know
like there's hope here
right like there's hope for us to win
and that's when captain universe
manifests right and it's just like
don't lie like do not do that tony stark
do not cede hope where there is none you
promised us a great machine of salvation
yet you built no
such thing do you know what lasting
thing you've built anthony stark you've
built
nothing you built a house on lies the
universe is dying
everything is dying tony stark we're all
dying humanity the whole nine yards the
multiverse is going to end and what's
worse
you have known it all along and that is
true
that's the worst sin of tony stark tony
stark knew there was
no way to stop the incursions when he
found out during the events original sin
that the living tribunal had died when
when the watcher grabbed tony stark and
brought him to the moon and showed him
the corpse of the living tribunal that's
when tony stark realized there was no
saving anything right now tony stark
found the body of a living tribunal
before the events of the incursions even
happened
and then like once black panther called
together the illuminati you know because
of the incursions
that's when it all kind of came together
for tony stark because up to that point
it was kind of like okay there's some
threat out there that killed the living
tribunal that's a big deal what could
this threat possibly be
and then once reid richards and had
talked to black swan and black swan said
the multi-version of universes colliding
into each other then iron man
immediately realized whatever it was
that caused these incursions led to the
death of a living tribunal and if the
living tribunal died there's nothing
that can save us and so
everything that's happened right his
participation in the illuminati the
formation of the avengers machine all of
that
has all been a distraction despite every
suggestion he's ever made to anybody
anything he's ever said to anyone
involving the possibility of success the
possibility of hope the idea that they
could possibly win
it's all been a lie he knew they could
never win he knew there was nothing they
could do to ever stop the incursions he
knew that there was no way for the day
to be saved and that everything was
inevitably going to die that's just the
way that it was and yet despite
knowing all that he didn't tell a soul
he didn't say a thing
he never said anything to anybody he
didn't tell reed richards he didn't tell
captain america
he didn't tell anybody that he kept it
to himself that's the center he let them
all believe that they could possibly
have a chance to win
instead of preparing for their own
demise he let them believe they could
succeed
and that's the worst thing because had
he actually told them what was going on
there may have been a chance for success
now switch over to what's going on right
now right because that meeting took
place a month before switch over to
what's going on right now right with so
much of the fleet
you know of the the the armada having
been destroyed through the combination
of
advanced idea mechanics using their
weapon you know basically channeling the
power of the earth as well as the uh
planet destroyer of captain america
before both those devices went down or
were destroyed or what have you that you
end up having
uh tony stark basically running up to
the dyson sphere by flying up to the
dyson sphere and powering it up right
charging this up
as it begins to charge up you've got
mentor from the shiar empire who hits a
gladiator says hey man like we're
detecting a massive spike from the local
star
now their assumption is the stars going
supernova remember that's what's been
happening
across the universe that the star is
beginning to go supernova and there's no
possible way they can get out there in
time but then suddenly tony stark
charges it up takes the power of the
star which basically channels it towards
the dyson sphere and then when that
happens
it literally just gets fired on the
entirety of the armada and wipes out
pretty much all of them right fires a
giant chunk out of the sun but he
literally i'm sorry out of the moon but
he shoots the sun
at the armada and incinerates them
pretty much all of them
it also hits what would be the earth but
remember the earth is currently
out of phase with the rogue planet in
phase and so all it does is annihilate
the rogue planet that's that's all it
does
right it keeps the earth intact it keeps
the earth safe but basically
iron man saved everybody and so from
here we switch back over to the ultimate
universe again we kind of covered that
in a previous video the ultimate
universe has been around since the year
2000 and so on i think at this point
most of you guys know what was going on
with that but you've got the ultimate
universe version of reed richards who
calls together
hawkeye of the ultimates which is
basically the ultimate universe version
of the avengers so like the avengers
from the mcu more or less
and then you know general nick fury and
when he calls them together of course he
brings them here
in order to meet with thanos and maximus
the mad of the cabal who of course
arrived here from the main marvel
universe right during one of the
incursions and so it's one of these
things where he basically tells them hey
look uh i haven't told you guys what's
been going on right like nick fury you
brought me here to be a part of shield
in order to prepare for all the worst
case scenarios and we're at the worst of
the worst case scenarios and when nick
fury asks what it is they're talking
about the responsive read is okay
like we need to take you like i need to
show you what's going on right like i
can't necessarily
uh you know i can't really tell you i
mean i guess i could but it's better if
you see it and so like essentially an
incursion's happening now right the
final incursion between the main marvel
universe and the ultimate universe and
what reed ends up doing
is taking them to that place within the
incursion point right where you
basically end up seeing both earths and
he takes him there and says that within
a matter of
hours that earth is potentially going to
crash into ours and if it does it's
going to lay waste to the entirety of
our earth like it's literally going to
destroy our entire universe
when he has thanos kind of explain
thanos basically says like
what was an infinite number of universes
is now down to only you know basically
two final universes there's only two
universes left and the entirety of the
multiverse us
and them and what awaits you on that
world are horrors that you couldn't
imagine
the greatest of possible heroes the
greatest heroes that you could have ever
possibly met in your entire life right
that was the big difference between the
ultimate universe and the maine marvel
universe the main marvel universe was
the traditional heroes right the way
that stanley and jack kirby built them
heroes that pretty much you know more
often than not
do great things the ultimate universe
was really really contained heroes who
were more morally ambiguous they were
willing to do bad things in order to
achieve good goals right it was a
universe of anti-heroes more or less in
a lot of different ways and so thanos is
like if you want to if you want your
world to survive if you want your
universe to survive you have to
annihilate that earth and everybody on
it it's the only possible way for you to
win and so in response to that
nick fury calls together basically all
shield personnel to the triskelion and
and that's kind of the cool thing
remember just assume this is the marvel
cinematic universe it's technically not
but it makes it easier to relate to and
he tells everybody here
like this is a volunteer only mission
but if you stayed here then i assume
you're willing to be part of it you know
we have final hours we have final
hours here until this incursion takes
place the only thing that we can really
do
to survive this whole thing is to
annihilate that world over there right
it's to basically
wipe out everybody on that world and
everyone on it and so from there you
switch over to the main marvel universe
you've got captain america you've got
reed richard susan storm captain marvel
beast you got james rhodes and it's them
kind of having this discussion and
really sort of filling them in
on who it is that we saved and what they
end up doing here is is kind of having
this discussion on who it is that gets
to go aboard
the the life raft right who gets to
survive on this life raft and who
doesn't now
this is the big difference between these
two universes because the ultimate
universe was filled with heroes whose
morality was a lot more ambiguous
like it's not really okay let's evacuate
and save as many people as we can
it's let's kill those guys over there
right let's just destroy them save our
universe and everything will be okay the
main marvel universe for the most part
traditional heroes was really kind of
about let's save our world right
um let's save as many people as we can
and so that's when they kind of reveal
we're basically bringing scientists
right we're bringing the most capable
people normal humans those who don't
really have
the kind of uh the ability to like
rebuild worlds they're not really going
to be coming with us right like we're
gonna we gotta leave them behind but the
big conversation the big talking point
here is
do we bring tony stark do we bring iron
man here we don't know whether we should
or not because there are two tony starks
there's iron man as we used to know him
and there's the superior iron man now
right the one who was inverted during
the events of axis basically became a
massive [ __ ] and we don't really
know what to do with him anymore right
he's not the tony stark that we knew and
at the end of the day
everybody kind of agrees no like we're
not going to bring tony stark like tony
stark he's lost that privilege he's the
best builder that we have but he's not
the only builder that we have right
there are people who could do
something similar to what he could do
not on the same level that he could but
at the end of the day second best
is better than first place if the person
in first place could potentially be the
ruin of us
all right so they end up leaving tony
stark behind and it's one of these
things where like captain america tells
he asked james rose how do i find
like how do i find tony stark right if
this is really the last days
and this is going to be the end of all
things then like then we settle all
family business right all debts get
taken care of here tell me tony stark
like tell me where he is i want to track
him down i want to find him and i want
to bring like
i want to settle up that's exactly what
i want to do from there we switch over
to the white house
and this is probably one of the coolest
moments of the whole story we switch
over to the white house black panther is
basically meeting with barack obama that
president right i mean this is this is i
think completed like 2014
right so at the end of obama's term but
he meets with obama and he says okay so
like
everything's basically ending like
everything's coming to an end like the
universe like the earth is going to die
like the the universe is going to end
there's nothing you can do to stop this
right he says i'm telling you because
people need to know when their time is
up right people need to know
when their times run out and they need
to hear this from someone they can trust
they will trust you more than they will
trust us as superheroes i mean look at
things like secret invasion house of m a
civil war we've routinely betrayed the
trust of people
across the world and obama asked you
know there's something that we can do
there has to be something that can be
done
there has to be someone somewhere
capable of doing something like
isn't there anyone willing to help us
and black panther says there was
like i was the person that could have
helped you but instead you took my
nation and you handed it over to the
cabal because it was what they what they
told you they wanted in order to try to
protect you you fell for their roots
right you handed
my country over to a pack of wolves and
they destroyed it so i could have helped
you but you screwed me over
so bye like i'm leaving you to the walls
i'm leading you to your fate you know
you screw me
over i screw you over that's just the
way that it is and it's one of the
it's like this perfect revenge moment
right it's like oh my god we're the
government
man i had no idea there were
consequences for the things we do well
welcome to the world of consequences
president you know the last stop is you
right this is it's like it's just
it's this amazing this is amazing thing
right and so like you end up having like
like like a member of the military where
i remember the cabinet who's like we can
scramble our military we scramble our
jets and it's like no you can't there's
it's over there's nothing you can do
like why would you come back with such
an asinine to the suggestion of like
scrambling fighter jets like what are
fighter jets gonna do like
i am i'm like the the third or fourth
smartest person in the world and i'm
telling you
there's nothing you can do and you you
goofball
general is are suggesting that you
scramble jets
like are you serious man like come on
you know like there's a reason why
superheroes are up here and you're down
there because while we've been working
on ways to save the universe
you want to scramble jets like that's
it's this amazing response it's just
it's this amazing thing and that's where
black panther says like like that's it
and like a member of the secret service
tells them like you people were supposed
to save us
and the response to black panther gives
is like you know what i've learned
through all this there was never any
saving any of you guys right there's
nothing that we could do to save the
world but this is a two-fold explanation
on the surface it's there's nothing that
we could have done to save the world
below the surface is there's nothing we
could have done to have saved humanity
anyway right you guys showed your darker
side when you handed my nation over the
cabal what i've learned about you guys
as humanity over the years that i've
been a superhero since i first stepped
foot in the rest of the world and left
wakanda behind as i learned
you as humans are irredeemable you guys
there's there's nothing good about you
there's nothing great about you that
have left to your own devices you will
do whatever you need to do to save your
own skin you people humanity is
inherently bad
because unlike those of us who try to go
on and do great things you serve your
baser needs you serve your base your
desires and you don't think about
anybody but yourself so if the world is
ending and the universe is going to end
i say good riddance because all of
creation is better off without baseline
humans who think about themselves and
nothing else
it's amazing right it's literally black
panther just
letting everybody have it right just
just like letting humanity have it
because the reality is he's always felt
that way when black panther first joined
the avengers i mean you go when you read
the like marvel comics you read those
stories
black panther admitted on one occasion
he joined the avengers to spy on them to
make sure they weren't going to be a
credible threat to wakanda but in all
the time that he spent like the wakandan
people were always focused
on bettering themselves right that was
the idea that was the drive of the
wakandan people to just improve
themselves
sure they were loyal to their king but
the purpose of their king was to keep
them protected and to try to move them
into the future
you step outside of wakanda which is in
a lot of ways almost kind of like this
idyllic paradise place right this utopia
you step one foot outside of wakanda and
you have the rest of the world which is
kind of like just this this trashy place
where everything's falling apart right
it's just like the crappiest things the
world have to offer
is anything that's not wakanda right
people who are looking to just satisfy
their own base needs who are only
looking for themselves who are only
looking to see how they can make
themselves better how they can get
themselves to a higher place right who
don't really care about anybody but
themselves like an inherently selfish
race of people that inhabit a world
he felt that way over and over and over
again right it's one of the reasons why
he just
had such a huge disconnect with the
human race because he only ever really
saw them as selfish organisms who like
what is it agent smith said
from from the matrix like they just move
to one location and they
multiply and they consume every natural
resource until every natural resource is
consumed and then they move to the next
place right humanity is a virus
and so it's kind of cool to you know
kind of interesting to see it that way
and so from there
we end up switching over to captain
america finally tracking down iron man
right he manages to uh to access uh
basically you know the the stark
underground building right you know kind
of uh starks you know base of operations
where he stays off the grid and of
course there's all these war machine
armors coming in and they're kind of a
distraction because what it does is it
allows captain america
to access the base of tony stark by kind
of you know
copying the signature of james rhodes
and when he finally gets finally catches
up to him
this is when all bets are off and all
debts get settled it's a straight up
knock down drag out brawl
between iron man and captain america and
this fight has been a long time coming
ever since the events of civil war this
has been a long time coming ever since
civil war the trust between iron man and
captain america has been virtually
non-existent right it's it's just been a
tenuous alliance at best
and over time captain america has more
and more and more lost faith in tony
stark that tony stark sided with
superhuman registration he cited against
the superhero community now tony stark's
argument during the original civil war
was
if we don't if we don't you know
regulate ourselves the government will
do it to do it for us and so it's better
to be
on the devil's right hand than in his
path captain america didn't see it that
way he saw it like an encroachment on
freedom that's what he saw
the right of superheroes to function
according to their own wimp total
dichotomies on on this on this notion
but for captain america it goes much
bigger than that
because he basically he tells he tells
iron man right pummeling him beating the
crap out of him like literally defecting
deflecting every single blast that iron
man has using a shield and just just
crushing tony stark he says like i want
to hear it i want to hear you tell me
that you lied i want to hear you tell me
that you knew
ever since the beginning of all this
since the the reformation of the
illuminati the formation of the avengers
machine
ever since you saw the death of the
living tribunal on the moon i want to
hear you
say it that you knew there was no way we
could survive this that you knew there
was no way we could get past this that
you knew that we were all going to die
that everything was going to come to an
end i want to hear you say it and i want
to hear you tell me that you lied to the
whole superhero community but you knew
there was no way that we could come out
on top i want to hear it i want to hear
you tell me that and finally after after
just getting crushed and decimated iron
man finally admits and he says i lied i
knew
i knew the whole time and i never told
anybody i didn't tell you i didn't tell
anyone that i knew
there was no way for us to stop this
that the multiverse was going to end
and we were powerless that all i did was
give you guys a false sense of hope that
all i did was tell you guys you could
win when i knew you couldn't
like uh yes yes that's my that's my sin
that's the worst thing that i ever did
but do you know what i would what i
would change if i could do it all over
again do you know what i would have done
differently and he says
nothing i would have i would have done
the exact same thing that i did last
time
because of what use are you like what
what what could you have done
captain america like in the face of the
living tribunal's death
and the collapse of the multiverse what
could any of us have done what could any
of us have done here what could we have
saved how could we have stopped all of
this like you're talking about forces
that killed the living tribunal what
would we have done
all you would have done is you would
have said we could find a way to do it
and you would have hoped against hope
and you would have done everything you
could and it would have led to this
anyway
at least you had something right at
least there was some sliver of hope
if i tricked all of you if i lied to all
of you then like we would have had some
sliver of hope some possibility of
success
because all of you guys were too dumb to
realize there was nothing you could do
and so with these two guys fighting
against each other duking it out
ultimately both iron man and captain
america die
when a helicarrier comes crashing down
and smashes both of them and the reason
why that helicarrier is here is because
the ultimate universe has launched this
invasion of the maine marvel universe
general nick fury reed richards from the
ultimate universe
ultimate hawkeye they're all here and
they're raining down hellfire and
brimstone
with that being said guys this concludes
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers run
one of the greatest stories ever told i
absolutely adore it following this
it goes into secret wars so i'm gonna
leave it up to you guys
do we remaster secret wars do we just
stop
do we do like the last days right do we
do we cover what like black widow and
punisher and all these characters we're
doing
as all this is happening right now right
as this invasion is going on do we cover
the last day's story lines what was loki
doing during this time what
what all was happening i leave it to you
guys let me know down in the comment
section but if you guys are new here the
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign